can we talk about this pandemic then
for a second so how do we
there's obviously huge amount of
economic pain that people are feeling
there's a huge incentive
and medical pain uh health
just all psychological there's a huge
incentive to figure this out
to walk along the trajectory of
reducible
of reducibility uh there's a there's a a
lot of
disparate data you know people
understand generally how viruses spread
but it's very
complicated because there's a lot of
uncertainty
there's a there could be a lot of
variability also like
so many obviously a nearly infinite
number of variables that
uh that represent human interaction
and so you have to figure out inter from
the perspective of
reducibility figure out which variables
are really important in this kind of uh
from an epidemiological perspective
so why aren't we you kind of said that
we're clearly failing well i think it's
a complicated thing so so i mean you
know when this pandemic started up
you know i happened to be in in the
middle of being about to release this
whole physics project yes
but i thought you know timing is just uh
little bit but but um but you know but i
thought you know i i
should do the public service thing of
you know trying to understand what i
could about the pandemic and you know
we've been
curating data about and all that kind of
thing but but you know so i started
looking at the data
and started looking at modeling and i
decided it's just really hard
you need to know a lot of stuff that we
don't know about human interactions
it's actually clear now that there's a
lot of stuff we didn't know about
viruses
um and about the way immunity works and
so on and um
it's you know i think what will come out
in the end is there's a certain amount
of
of what happens that we just kind of
have to
trace each step and see what happens
there's a certain amount of stuff where
there's going to be a big narrative
about
this happened because you know of t-cell
immunity this could
happen because there's this whole giant
sort of field of
of asymptomatic viral stuff out there
you know there will be a narrative
and that narrative whenever there's a
narrative that's kind of a sign of
reducibility
but when you just say let's from first
principles figure out what's going on
then you can potentially be stuck in
this kind of
mess of irreducibility we just have to
simulate each step
and you can't do that unless you know
details about you know human interaction
networks and so on and so on and so on
the thing that has
has been very sort of frustrating to see
is the mismatch between people's
expectations about what science can
deliver
and what science can actually deliver so
to speak because people have this idea
that you know it's science
so there must be a definite answer and
we must be able to know that answer
and you know this is it is both uh
uh you know that when you've after
you've
played around with sort of little
programs in the computational universe
you don't have that intuition anymore
you know it's it's i always i'm always
fond of saying you know the
the the computational animals are always
smarter than you are that is
you know you look at one of these things
and it's like it can't possibly do such
and such a thing
then you run it and it's like wait a
minute it's doing that thing how does
that work
okay now i can go back and understand it
but that's the brave thing about science
is that in the chaos of the irreducible
universe
we nevertheless persist to find those
pockets that's kind of the whole point
that's like you say that the limits of
science but that
you know yes it's highly limited but
there's a hope there
and like there's so many questions i
want to ask here so one you said
narrative which is really interesting so
obviously from uh at every level of
society you look at twitter everybody's
constructing narratives about the
pandemic
about not just the pandemic but all the
cultural tension that we're going
through
so there's narratives but they're not
necessarily connected
to the underlying
reality of these systems
so our human narratives i don't even
know if they're
i don't like those pockets of
reduceability because we're
uh it's like constructing things that
are not actually representative of
reality
well and thereby not giving us like good
solutions to how to
predict the system look it it gets
complicated because you know people want
to say
explain the pandemic to me explain
what's going to happen in the future
like
yes but also can you explain it is there
a story to tell
what already happened in the past yeah
what's going to happen but i mean
and you know it's similar to sort of
explaining things in ai
or in any computational system it's like
like you know explain what happened well
it could just be
this happened because of this detail in
this detail in this detail and
a million details and there isn't a big
story to tell there's no
kind of big arc of the story that says
oh it's because you know there's a viral
field that has these properties and
people start showing symptoms
you know when when the seasons change
people will show symptoms and people
don't even understand you know seasonal
variation of flu for example
it's a it's a um uh it's something where
where you know that there could be a big
story or it could be just
a zillion little details that that mount
up see but
okay let's let's uh pretend that this
pandemic
like the coronavirus resembles something
like the one
d rule 30 cellular automata okay
so i mean that's how epidemiologists
model virus spread indeed yes there's
sometimes use cellular automata yes
and okay so you could say it's
simplistic but okay let's say
it it is it's representative of actually
what happens
uh you know the the dynamic of
you have a graph it probably is closer
to the hypergraph
um that's another funny thing
yeah as we were getting ready to release
this physics project we realized that a
bunch of things we'd worked out about
about foliations of causal graphs and
things were directly relevant to
thinking about contact tracing
yeah and interactions interesting cell
phones and so on which is really weird
but like it just feels like uh it feels
like we should be able to get some
beautiful core insight
about the spread of this particular
virus
on the hypergraph of human civilization
right
i tried i didn't i didn't manage to
figure it out but you're one person
yeah but i mean i think actually it's
it's a funny thing because it turns out
the um
the main model you know this sir model i
i only realized recently was invented by
the
the grandfather of a good friend of mine
from high school so
that was just a you know it's a weird
thing right
the question is you know okay so you
know
you know on this graph of how humans are
connected you know something about what
happens if this happens and that happens
that graph
is made in complicated ways that depends
on on all sorts of issues that
where we don't have the data about how
human society works well enough to be
able to make that graph
there's actually one of my kids did a
study of sort of what happens on
different kinds of graphs
and how robust are the results okay his
basic answer is
there are a few general results that you
can get that are quite robust
like you know a small number of big
gatherings is worse than a large number
of small gatherings
okay that's quite robust but when you
ask more detailed questions
it seemed like it just depends it
depends on details in other words it's
kind of telling you
in that case you know the irreducibility
matters so to speak
it's not there's not going to be this
kind of one
sort of master theorem that says and
therefore this is how things are going
to work
yeah but there's a certain kind of from
a graph perspective
the certain kind of dynamic to human
interaction
so like large groups and small groups
i think it matters who the groups are
for example you can imagine
large depends how you define large but
you can imagine groups of 30 people
as long like as long as they are uh
cliques or whatever like right as long
as the
outgoing degree of that graph is small
or something like that like you can
imagine
some beautiful underlying rule right
human dynamic interaction where i can
still be happy
where i can have a conversation with you
and a bunch of other people
that mean a lot to me in my life and
then stay away from the bigger
i don't know not going to a miley cyrus
concert or something like that and and
figuring out mathematically some nice
see this is an interesting thing so i
mean in you know this is the question of
what you're describing is kind of uh the
problem of
many situations where you would like to
get away from computational
irreducibility
classic one in physics is thermodynamics
the you know the second law of
thermodynamics the law that says you
know entropy tends to increase
things that you know start orderly tend
to get more disordered
or which is also the thing that says
given that you have a bunch of heat
it's hard heat is you know the
microscopic motion of molecules
it's hard to turn that heat into
systematic mechanical work
it's hard to you know just take
something being hot and turn that into
oh the
the you know the all the atoms are going
to line up and the bar of metal and the
piece of metal is going to shoot in some
direction that's
essentially the same problem as how do
you go from this
this computationally irreducible mess of
things happening and get something you
want out of it
that's right it's kind of mining you
know you're kind of now you know
actually i've i've understood in recent
years that
that the story of of thermodynamics is
actually precisely a story of
computational irreducibility
but it is a um it is already an analogy
you know you can you can kind of see
that is can you take the um
you know what you're asking to do there
is you're asking to go
from the um uh the kind of um the mess
of all these complicated human
interactions and all this kind of
computational processes going on and you
say
i want to achieve this particular thing
out of it i want to kind of extract
from the heat of what's happening i want
to kind of extract
this useful piece of sort of mechanical
work
that i find helpful i mean do you have a
hope for the pandemic
so we'll talk about physics but for the
pandemic can that be extracted
do you think well what's your intuition
the good news is
the curves basically you know for
reasons we don't understand
the curves you know the the clearly
measurable mortality cloves and so on
for the northern hemisphere have gone
down yeah but the bad news
is that it could be a lot worse for
future viruses and what this pandemic
revealed is we're highly unprepared
for the discovery of the pockets of
reducibility
within a pandemic that's much more
dangerous well
my guess is the specific risk of you
know viral pandemics
you know that the pure virology
and you know immunology of the thing
this will cause that to advance to the
point where this particular risk
is probably considerably mitigated but
you know
it's uh you know does is is the
structure of modern society robust to
all kinds of risks well the answer is
clearly no
and you know it's surprising to me the
extent to which people uh
you know as i say it's it's a it's kind
of scary actually
how much people believe in science that
is people say oh
you know because the science says this
that and the other will do this and this
and this
even though from a sort of common sense
point of view it's a little bit crazy
and and people are not prepared and it
doesn't really work in
in society as it is for people to say
well actually we don't really know how
the science works
people say well tell us what to do yeah
because then yeah what's the alternative
the for the masses
it's difficult to sit it's difficult to
meditate
on computational reducibility it's
difficult to sit right
it's not going to enjoy a good dinner
meal
while knowing that you know nothing
about the world i think this is a this
is a place where you know this is
this is what politicians you know and
political leaders do for a living so to
speak is you got to make some decision
about what to do and it's um tell some
narrative
that uh while amidst the mystery and
knowing not much about
the the past or the future still telling
a narrative that
somehow gives people hope that we know
what the heck we're doing
you